Hello Freak bitches speaking a lucrative,
I was with,
with Ian Edwards this weekend and,
uh,
Greg Fitzsimmons and Ian and I were flying
home and we were at the terminal and
we ran into this girl that,
uh,
Ian knew,
from the store and
apparently she's a stripper.
And,
uh,
she,
we were sitting down having a coffee
and she asked if she could sit with us.
I said,
yeah,
sure,
go ahead.
Sit with us.
And so she started talking about working
at spearmint Rhino Strip in and this
and that.
And she worked this weekend.
Yeah.
And she was coming back and you know,
she's just talking about,
you know,
everybody was cheap and this and that,
that and this.
And then she said she was
working with this girl.
She's working with this girl and the girl,
uh,
I go,
what percentage of the girls that you
work with are willing to have sex with
guys for money?
And she's like,
um,
there's quite a few.
She goes,
I worked with this one girl
this weekend who was like,
how lucrative do you get?
And she goes,
what?
She goes,
how lucrative too you get,
cause I be getting Lucas.
And she goes,
what do you mean lucrative?
Says I'll go,
I'll go back to a dues hotel room
for $1,000 I'll get lucrative,
lucrative,
and this girl was married to a guy,
apparently that is not gay,
but is a dancer and he
dances for men and he does.
He's gay for pay.
Yeah,
he's gay.
I think her husband is her husband.
Well,
like five guys were on a train or
it's so fucking unacceptable,
dude.
Hey,
one night he doesn't have to
work for the rest of the month.
Okay,
how's that?
How's your sleep?
Are you sleeping well?
Is Everything good?
Can you out of your fucking mind?
He's lucrative.
He's real.
I saw that like a MTV,
MTV thing.
They did that when the
guy where he was like,
I'm not gay and these six guys,
we're about to blow these six guys.
I saw that and they were all clowning him.
Do you remember that?
They were all openly gay and they're like,
dude,
you're sucking your Dick Today.
And he's like,
I'm getting fucking
getting super lucrative.
They had a girlfriend too,
and his girlfriend was like,
I don't like it,
but it's really his job.
And his Crawford was like kind of homely
and he's a good looking guy and he's a,
and I remember the line that
he had to say in the video,
anal sex is the bomb.
That's when he had to
say before these years,
ran a train on them.
Fuck man.
He's just getting lucrative,
lucrative.
I get pretty lucrative.
Ho
how,
how crazy chick yet in a Vegas
strip club on fight weekend.
This girl,
man,
I was just a wished we had more time
and she could tell me more crazy,
more lucrative stories.
How lucrative do you get?
What's that?
Um,
stripper.
He shows me this video
on his iPhone and it's a,
Beyonce has a free concert in central
park and on this giant screens fucking
enormous.
A hundred foot screen.
She has all Ronda Rousey's words playing
out like the script of it while Ron is
talking,
Ron is talking about not
being a do nothing bitch.
She's like,
every muscle in my body
has a functional purpose.
I'm not,
some do nothing bitch sitting around
waiting for some millionaire to come home.
Fuck me.
And which like to like chick that hustle.
Yeah.
Chicks that hustle that
is like they'll actually,
yeah,
fuck yeah.
Yeah.
But to all those do nothing
pitches out there that's like,
Hey,
what the fuck?
I mean,
how's your family?
I mean I want to work.
I wasn't like,
I'm trying to get lucrative.
I ain't trying to hustle that hard.
How lucrative are you willing to get?
Cause I get lucrative.
I get pretty lucrative.
That's amazing.
Is that a shirt next week?
Lucrative.
I'm trying to get lucrative.
I uh,
I retweeted Ian Edwards.
Uh,
his,
uh,
you know,
he's a appear this
weekend at the punchline.
By the way,
if you're in Sacramento,
he's one of the funniest
fucking dudes is working today.
Fucking funny.
Look good.
He wrote me after I tweeted it to him.
Oh
thanks man.
It's going to be lucrative.
We're both laughing about it on the plane.
We couldn't stop saying it.
How lucrative do you get,
cause I kept pretty low grid.
I do.
You mean lucrative?
It's really good to surround yourself
with people who inspire you because they,
they talk about having a cognitive
model for behavior change.
Like if you're trying to
get better in some way,
uh,
if you can visual,
if you know somebody who's already done
it or doing positive things in their
lives,
it's,
it requires less energy for your
brain to imagine yourself doing it.
Like if you're,
if you,
if you don't,
if you're not trying to be anybody who's
trying to get healthy or trying to get
fit or whatever it is,
you're,
it's like,
it's literally harder to imagine.
And so it's like more exhausting for
you to try to imagine yourself getting
better.
Whereas if you're surrounded
by people who are doing it,
it becomes familiar to your brain.
There's all sorts of examples
that your brain can call on.
Um,
it literally takes less energy for you
to imagine yourself actually doing it.
And weirdly,
they found at Stanford University using,
uh,
like avatars.
If you can see an Avatar that
is designed to look like you,
like doing the sort of
things you want to do,
like you know,
being really physically fit,
like working out in the game world.
If you just watch an avatar custom
design to look like you doing that,
it lowers the cognitive
threshold for you to do it.
And then you will do more in real life.
You'll like,
you know,
you will work out more or you'll spend
more time committed to those goals just
by having watched this sort of mirror
version of yourself having done it.
But he's that guy now
that really is who he is.
He's like all the time,
four hours.
You call
him up in the middle of the night.
He's dice man.
Yeah.
He became that guy.
We uh,
I opened up for him for like two,
three years.
He really,
yeah,
he picked me out of the comedy story.
He came up to me and uh,
at first he goes,
um,
you know what you should do.
I said,
what?
When you go on stage,
put a sack
pants and then you'll be like the
comedian who's just got a big cock
and this is like,
this is like my guy I looked up to
and he's telling me.
And then I actually went home that night,
gone.
Should I do,
should I be cat gay?
So,
uh,
anyway,
we was just kind of beard,
little friendship.
And he asked me if I wanted to go to
Las Vegas with him at the Stardust hotel
and I'm like,
call my parents.
I go,
I'm opening up for dice
clay at the stone us.
My mom was like,
you made it,
you made it.
Wow.
So they all came out to see and
I hung out with them on the road.
And uh,
the first time we played Vegas,
I'm like,
I can't believe I'm here.
Wayne Newton theater.
I wonder what we're going to do,
you know,
excited and we'll go,
probably go out dinner and
we'll go out to a club,
hang by the pool,
probably got a Cabana.
And he goes,
we'll go and grow.
We're going to furniture shopping today.
I go,
Huh.
And Las Vegas.
So we went furniture shopping because
he had a house out there and he was
furnishing his house.
So we would go to furniture
stores and he would told me,
sit on the couch.
That's it.
When you think,
say grand guy,
it's better than anything.
I got it at my house.
It's fantastic.
And we would go to eat.
I mean this was a process.
We were laying on carpets.
I just see if the carpet
was comfortable and uh,
I'm like,
uh,
okay.
I guess this is what you,
you do.
This is my first time on the
road and were furniture shop,
but let's go on.
Then I made it a casino.
Maybe we go for dinner and he's like,
are you kidding me?
It's like the Beatles.
If I go out,
that's like the,
it's like mania.
People going to lose their mind.
I can look,
let's try it.
And sure enough,
we went through the
casino yet is the glasses.
He had like some big glitter ball on his
back of his jacket that we went through
it
and it was like,
it was fantastic.
It was like,
Oh wow,
this is what he's talking about.
So to swarm them,
right.
Just warm them.
He's got like a loyal fan base.
Oh yeah.
It's crazy.
Okay.